you know let's yeah let's dive into that
a little bit but i mean like like i've
watched now um in my lifetime on screens
unfold the falkland war which is pretty
much more of like a one-way
source of information because you'd sit
there and you turn on the tv and it
would just you know give you info we
live in an environment today where you
can actually interact with people
creating content and providing the
information with social media then we've
had what other words we have since then
iraq one and two afghanistan how many
times and all the various conflicts sort
of in in between there
and
you know it's only recently that i've
unplugged like i've been very honest
about this like i've you know i've just
believed everything they told me you
know for the vast majority of my life
it's only been recently that i've been
like well hold on a second that doesn't
really add up
and one of the things that's really
stood out to me over the last couple
weeks is how quick
the mainstream media and the large
you know conglomerate media sources
politicians
anybody in any kind of position of power
has been so quick to
uh turn the attention away from beer bug
over to russian man bad
and it's gotten to the point where
they're like canceling
some of the strangest things like i've
seen them cancel
russian cats from competing in like
breeding competitions i've seen them
cancel
um some of the some of the most bizarre
stuff what else have we seen in the last
couple weeks
uh russian favorites we've seen the same
thing over here absolutely i think the
ballet was canceled over here nikki
keaton nikita wins i mean council from
f1 i've seen that right i say council
has been dropped from a house let's be
let's be realistic a lot of the big tech
companies have also restricted access to
their services in russia so for example
if you're a
14 year old kid that lives in moscow and
you have an xbox you can't play with it
anymore right because microsoft has
canceled you know access to i guess
online gaming you know for example so
it's like
the these like small
and incremental cancellations you know
some might say well it's designed to
annoy the public maybe to have them
uprise against the government sort of
thing and the hope but that could be
yeah
yeah like i think there's an argument to
that as well but i mean like the
cancellation of some of the most bizarre
things i don't think i've ever seen this
before have you guys
i don't think so i mean
i look at this and i quote this and
people will have a go at me here for
this because of course the two one
involves a significant amount of death
another doesn't but the reason that um
the reason that the russian forces uh
would target um housing establishments
and everything else say in syria that
kind of stuff we're seeing the same
thing as they were as they're working
their way through ukraine they're
targeting blocks of flats is to
demoralize the population it is to make
sure the population hasn't got a home
population is seeking peace like they
haven't got a car anymore i haven't got
a means of um
income anymore all these kind of things
and we're just doing it in kind of a
different way don't get me wrong it's
not you know it's not as brutal as
what's happening there and that needs to
stop immediately but when we're
restricting all these services to
ordinary russians we're expecting these
russian people and russian people
they're like us by the way that you know
we are good people we're just managed
and everything by by people with
sometimes nefarious intent or they they
just got their own agenda and these
people they're expecting we're expecting
to go and take that fight to to the
streets and to protest and everything in
russia which i believe is illegal to
protest in russia i think 1600 people
have been
sort of taken into custody for
protesting that's what we're trying to
do so by restricting these services i
believe we're trying to get people to go
out on the streets in the campaign
against what putin's doing in ukraine
that's that's all it is i think it's
despicable rich to target um what i
would say an innocent populace really
with all these restrictions i mean we
know that russian cats are dicks we
should never rush in cats in these kind
of competitions anyway but everything
else um i was a supporter of nikita
mazupin i felt that was a young man
trying to do his best after a really bad
start in life okay son of a son of a
billionaire or whatever and oligarch but
you know he come he was fighting back
from that charge of grabbing his
girlfriend whatever and everyone's
launching at him you know the virtuous
i've never done anything wrong when
they're right in the like we're
launching on this young dude trying to
make the best out of a career in f1 i'm
supporting that dude because he's
russian i mean can you listen listen to
what we're saying because he's russian
we're gonna stop him driving in formula
one because he's russian do you know
that crystal nash in germany you know
where where all the germans are going
around breaking all the jews winners i
thought we learned from that back in the
second world war it's happening again
now in germany they're going to be
smashing up
smashing up russian restaurants and
stuff yeah
yeah i've seen that there's there's
germans that are destroying russian
restaurants and like uh stores you know
small like boutique mom and pop shops um
there was um there was a few um you know
millionaires with yachts that had them
seized apparently in mediterranean ports
like what did they have to do with putin
or a war in ukraine and it's like
they're they're building the systematic
campaign and it's just like you know it
sounds and feels a lot like the whole
like anybody that didn't want to take a
jab then they would call you an
anti-vaxxer and then they would sort of
segregate you and separate you out
you know like you're one of the bad guys
because you know and it and like you
know today on twitter i saw boycott
mcdonald's was trending and i'm like
okay well what's this about and i
clicked it and apparently all of the um
npcs are trying to convince other npcs
to not buy mcdonald's because mcdonald's
hasn't boycotted or cancelled you know
their services in russia
right well we're in cancer culture right
i mean so
it's always been there's always been
some element of that because you're
tribal you know as a species human
beings are tribal and so um there's
always been an element of segregation
you through culture racial and stuff
like that when there's these wars but
we're also now in a canceled culture
where
we want to feel good about ourselves for
essentially doing nothing right and so
oh i boycotted russian vodka i'm doing
my part right
like nobody cares about that chris is in
the chat he said uh russian vodka was
taken off the shelves here in ontario
the lcbo is a liquor control board of
ontario so doug ford which is our
premiere you know decided well we're
going to teach the russians a lesson and
take their vodka off the shelves yeah
that'll show them you know like it's
just virtue signaling because we're not
really doing anything because sanctions
classically have not actually done
anything to motivate uh putin or the
russians or to do anything different
they we are doing they're pretty harsh i
mean so there is going to be economic
damage from that but it's not going to
stop them from shelling it's not going
to stop them from fighting so it's not
real you know what i mean there's some
damage but it's not it's not actually
but they can feel we can we can feel
that like we're doing something and
that's what's important is emotions
there's a comment here from the
competent man he says the best part of
this bs sanction thing is how you as how
energy transactions are exempted so
europe is still buying oil and gas from
russia and if i'm not mistaken there's
still oil and gas being sold to america
from russia is that oh is that correct
yeah because they don't want the pr even
though it would it impact us the least
here in the united states
it's the approval ratings and all that
stuff they don't want it to go down when
at the pump the price goes up a bit they
don't want that hey guys i really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you